welcome to the new Chase Sapphire Lounge
at Boston Logan International Airport the
lounge is the first of its type in the United
States upon entering the lounge you'll have to
present your Chase Sapphire Reserve card and
its accompanying priority pass membership card
the lounge is a large dining area with self-serve
and made-to-order food options you can order food
right to your table by scanning a QR code
walking toward the back of the lounge you'll
find a bar and Tap Room the bar reserves wine
beer traditional and signature cocktails the
booths at the back of the lounge are particularly
useful for working at the lounge since they're
outfitted with power outlets and provide a bit of
privacy if you need to take a zoom or a phone call
there's also a wellness room with five private
stations so you can enjoy a massage away from
the hustle and bustle of the Airport Boston is
the first of many airports to get a sapphire
Lounge you'll find one other Sapphire Lounge in
Hong Kong International Airport and others are
soon to open around the US it's an Ultra Modern
take on the airport lounge and its amenities
make it a great place to relax or get work done
before your next trip other airports slated to
get a sapphire Lounge include New York LaGuardia
Philadelphia and San Diego International Airport